Argentina are the winners of the 2022
FIFA World Cup in Qatar
[Applause]
here's a quick recap of the
against France Argentina started the
game pressing the French defense high up
the field after 21 minutes the referee
pointed to the spot penalty for
Argentina Messi stepped up and
[Applause]
Argentina took the early lead then in
the 36th minute Argentina struck again
Angel Di Maria finished off a
counter-attack started by Lionel Messi
in their own halves the South Americans
finished the first half with a 2-0 lead
in the 71st minute Killian mbappe fired
France's first shot of the game it
sailed way over the goal 10 minutes
later for the second time in the game
the referee whistled for a penalty this
time for France upstepped Killian and
Bape
foreign
he gave France a Lifeline 2-1 with 10
minutes left just one minute later
ecstasy for France killing and bop it
tied the game with an incredible strike
from a tight angle 2-2 in the final
minutes of the game 18 frantic minutes
later neither team could break the tie
then late into extra time when Argentine
attacked sliced open the French defense
Lionel Messi did what Lionel Messi does
he scored the 98th International goal of
his career 3-2 to Argentina but just
when Argentina thought they had it a
strike from Killian mbappe hits Leandro
Paredes on the arm penalty to France
mbappe scored it 3-3 now after 120
Minutes the game would be decided by
penalties mbappe and Messi scored their
teams first then France missed their
next two Argentina made their next two
France finally scored one but Argentina
had the chance to win it with their
fourth penalty and
the solo monkey out scored it Argentina
of the 2022 FIFA World Cup champions
[Applause]